Alright, here we are at Layer 3 in the OSI model.
We've been slowly moving up.
Now if you remember how we equated the OSI model to a team, like a sports team for example,
usually you pick a captain of the team and that person is usually the one that has the
most leadership qualities, can inspire the others, can coordinate so that the team more
effectively achieves its goal.
Well, if you were to pick a captain of the OSI team, it would have to be the network
layer.
The network layer has some protocols within it that are really fundamental to what
networking is and how we allow communications across network itself.
And so the network layer and protocols that operate here that are part of TCPIP.
Remember how we implement the OSI model is through TCPIP and its family of protocols.
So there are protocols that operate at the network layer here that really drive everything
that happens and are the captain of the team.
That protocol has to be IP.
In fact, if you remember what we talked about earlier as far as the network layer is concerned,
it's really responsible for two really important capabilities and responsibilities that need
to happen across network.
And it's what you see here on your slide.
The first is what we call fragmentation, which means, for example, taking the email that
I'm sending you and breaking it down or fragmenting it into manageable chunks that are typically
called packets or data grams.
But then it's also the network layer through IP here that needs to deliver each of those
data grams to the destination using some sort of addressing scheme, which you know is
referred to as IP addressing.
So remember that the network layer includes the IP protocol, which is really responsible
for two very important things, fragmentation and addressing of those fragments so that
they can get to their destination.
Now, if we draw this, the unit of information that the network layer or IP uses at the network
layer is usually referred to as a packet.
But more appropriately, it should be called a data gram.
So if you look at what a data gram looks like, it really has two important components
to allow the network layer here and IP to not only deliver that information to you, but
as effectively as possible.
So if you look at the two components that make up a data gram or a packet, you're going
to have the data portion, which is also referred to as the payload by some people, most network
people will call it the payload.
But in order to get this data gram to its destination, we need addressing information
that is usually included in what we call the header portion of the data gram.
So this is the unit that IP, for example, uses at the network layer to do fragmentation,
which means breaking that email into data grams, but then allowing each of these data grams
to be delivered to its destination.
So those are the two important functions that the network layer through IP takes care
of.
Now, obviously what's important here is there needs to be fields in the header portion
of the data gram that allows this entire data gram to be delivered to its destination.
So there are fields in here called source IP address, destination IP address, and some
other fields that allow fragmentation and delivery through addressing, for example, at the network
layer.
Now that field called source IP address and destination IP address are 32 bits of information.
32 bits.
And what they've done is they've taken those 32 bits and divided it into four groups
of eight bits.
That's why you end up seeing IP addresses like the one you see on your slide here, right?
So you've got IP addresses that might look like something like this.
But really this represents the 32 bits that are in the header portion of the data gram.
You've just taken those 32 bits and divided it into four groups of eight bits.
Now if you do the math because this is bits, if you've got something that's 32 bits, there
are only so many finite, unique IP addresses that that can represent.
So if you do two to the 32 and work that out, it's going to equal just under 4.3 billion
unique IP addresses that can be referenced across any network like the internet.
And so that's a limitation that we have known about.
And something that has saved us in allowing us to have many more things connected to the
internet rather than this limitation is something called NAT that we're going to talk about
later on.
But this limitation that the industry has known for a number of years has led to the development
of something called IP version 6, which we're going to talk about later on.
But one of the things that they've done in IP version 6 is they've expanded the addressing
to actually 128 bits for both the source IP address and the destination IP address.
And something else that's relevant from a security perspective in IP version 6 is the
inclusion of security called IPSec, which will add authentication and encryption natively
into the IP version 6 protocol when everybody's using it.
And so the next thing that you see up here on your slide is not anything that's relevant
from the perspective of you having to understand each of these different IEEE document numbers
that you see here.
The important thing to remember at this point is the importance of that organization called
the IEEE.
The IEEE is the Institute of Electric and Electronic Engineers.
And they are a bunch of bright people that get together when a technology first appears
or improves, for example.
And what they do is they sit down and ratify, which means they agree on what a technology
needs to look like so that vendors and anyone else that wants to offer products related
to that technology will have to conform to the standards and not go off in their own direction.
And so when they ratify some of these technologies and what they need to look like, they issue
what are called IEEE document numbers.
And you're probably familiar with the family of 802.11 IEEE specifications for wireless
lands.
And as we've evolved, for example, what we used to have was 802.11A and then B came
along and then G came along and then N came along and AC came along, they've ratified
each of those standards so that everybody conforms to those standards.
That's the importance of the IEEE.
So there's different specifications for different technologies that exist out there.
You don't need to memorize them all, obviously, for purposes of the exam.